build it dry play it Vsauce this is your
home for some of the coolest creations
from everyday people
this is bdp building young og creates
incredible realistic and refined
sculptures out of tires he uses
different kinds of tires depending on
the area of the animal he's trying to
create areas of the face often include
bike tires while tractor tires might be
used for the body for some realistic
future Ramah sculptures raelynne created
nimbler Professor Farnsworth Leela and
of course dr. Zoidberg skittles meet
link skittle ink meet skittle Mario and
recycling paper takes on new meaning for
artist Jennifer Collier she turns
newspapers maps letters and basically
any other printed materials into
repurposed art drive Darth Vader has a
ton of fan art but Jordan Conlan
actually made a video of himself
creating this piece he created this
Vader speed painting in only an hour and
33 minutes
Holly Moss gave us this popular
Wolverine Batman illusion but he has a
ton of other great pop culture
influenced works including alternate
movie posters t-shirts and even this the
1988 Gallery is featuring the old-school
video game show right now and here are
some of the many many epic pieces
[Music]
and Shawn harder has some alternate
universe movie posters that take actors
from the past and integrate them with
different iconic films play here's the
main theme from The Legend of Zelda on
marimba this mesmerizing stop-motion
music video is direct from Sweden and
it's for a song called respawn
the beat bearing creates rhythms by
arranging ball bearings on a grid
[Music]
finally magic machines hey mr. video is
comprised entirely of popular animated
gifts from around the web
we're not done yet submit your own
beauty piece at facebook.com slash
Vsauce gaming and as always thanks for
watching